et notre entité politique ce matin cet
ami de montchalin bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nos visites de la transition
écologique et la cohésion des
territoires et on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représenté par julien lécuyer louis du
nord bonjour générargues oriane bonjour
madame la ministre evènement chalon va
commencer par ce qui s'est passé hier au
parlement européen est d'abord ce rejet
surprise par les députés européens de la
réforme du marché du carbone c'est l'une
des réformes fondamentales pour que
l'union européenne puisse atteindre ses
objectifs de neutralité carbone en 2050
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle pour vous ce
projet d'abord on est intransigeant et
vos objectifs donc c'est pas la fin de
l'histoire les négociations vont
reprendre et nous voulons absolument
être en capacité de tenir l'objectif
unanimement partagée par tous les
parlementaires européens en tout cas ce
qu'il à l'époque l'avait approuvée mais
surtout tous les pays européens de la
neutralité carbone en 2050 avec une
étape importante et 2030 ce qui s'est
passé hier je pense qu'il faut le
décrire aux français c'est une alliance
en fait des contraires d'un côté une
gauche qui fait de l'écologie de manière
assez incantatoire à certains moments et
qui dit au fond il faut que tout tout de
suite soit interdite mais sans prendre
en compte aussi les réalités
l'accompagnement est juste est ce qu'on
est capable d'atteindre des objectifs au
rythme global et de l'autre côté une
extrême droite qui aiment les clés mais
amélie manche a lancé excusez moi vous
parlez en effet des ambitions mais ce
qui est dans de nombreux rapports dont
celui du giec ne montre quand même qu'à
une certaine une certaine urgence et les
objectifs sur lequel deux dont on parle
c'était c'est 2032 ou 2034 - 63% ou
moins 67% est ce que ça ne valait pas le
coup justement d'être plus ambitieux et
finalement de répondre aux urgences
climatiques juste qu'on soit clair avec
ceux qui nous écoutent nous ne
transigerons pas avec nos objectifs on
doit réduire de 55 % des émissions d'ici
2030 par rapport à 1990 on ne change pas
ça et on ne transige pas avec la
neutralité carbone en 2050 et pourtant
tous les organismes disent que la france
est en retard sur ses objectifs
est donc si bien sûr qu'il faut qu'ils
aient un texte et donc il faut qu'on
renégocie bon qu'on soit d'accord sur un
texte si on n'a rien on va pas y arriver
donc le but c'est qu'entre rien et le
rejet d'hier on travaille mais ce qui
est important a à dire prenez la voiture
électrique l'électrification notre
mobilité l'horizon de 2035 2040 qui
était posée 2035 au parlement européen
en france on avait dit 2040 pourquoi
c'est important vous de me dire c'est
pas demain c'est important pour les
constructeurs automobiles pour que les
français qui les français qui pensent
qu'on va pas assez vite et sur certains
aspects je suis leur côté mais aussi des
français qui disent on aimerait bien
pouvoir faire sa transition mais pour
l'instant c'est un luxe il faut qu'on
peut soit accompagnée il faut qu'on soit
vont aider à faire cette transition la
planification c'est ce qui réconcilie
avec un objectif à 2035 une transe est
sur certains sujets à 2040 pourquoi
c'est important ça permet à l'ensemble
des acteurs notamment industriels mais
aussi citoyen de savoir à quel rythme on
fait les choses pour qu'en 2050
seulement soit neutre j'ai mis 35 est ce
qu'on sera prêt ce que la france a sera
prêt demande énormément de bande de re
de recharge par exemple pour justement
accompagner cette émergence du du marché
du véhicule électrique est ce que l'on
est capable de le faire ailleurs
vous savez quand vous dites au manque de
bornes c'est vrai qu'il en faut qu'on il
en faut plus mais la semaine dernière
j'étais avec les ministres européens des
transports on a pris une décision
décisive a aussi pour qu'il y ait des
bornes et rick partout 50% des bornes en
europe sont en allemagne en france et
aux pays-bas ça veut dire que nous on
voit bien il en faut plus lui les pays
où on a encore une accélération beaucoup
plus forte à faire pour que cela soit
possible
objectifs ne sont pas allés regarder fin
2020 terre on est à 60 mille aujourd'hui
il en fait un million je crois
évidemment que c'est un immense effort
d'investissement regardés de la voiture
électrique
si aujourd'hui on est en train de parler
aux français pour dans 30 ans pendant 10
ans pour dans quelques mois quelques
d'ici la fin de l'année 2023 on puisse
vraiment se dire qu'il ya une solution
de voitures électriques à moins de 100
euros pour les ménages les plus modestes
si on dit voilà on fait la prime à la
conversion et un million de français qui
ont déjà changé de voiture c'est pas on
n'attend pas les bornes les jalons le
temps long pour faire au fait
aujourd'hui et moi mon ambition c'est
que vous avez une négociation européenne
l'unanimité sur la neutralité carbone
les discussions qui vont se poursuivre
des jalons qui sont posées mais juste
sur les discussions qui vont se
poursuivre qu'est ce qui vous garantit
qu'il y aura un test d'un texte est ce
que il faut faire des compromis est ce
qu'il faut aller plus dans le sens des
verts et de la gauche du coup toute
façon il va falloir faire des compromis
pour se mettre d'accord mais donc allé
au-delà de ce que vous aviez imaginé
initialement reprenait l'exemple du
départ de cette affaire quand moi
j'étais nommé ministre en 2019 et que
président de la république en mars 2010
9 me dit l'objectif que je te fixes avec
elisabeth bost remise la transition
écologique c'est de créer l'unanimité à
27 sur la neutralité carbone 2050
personne à l'époque ne pensais que
c'était possible nous y sommes arrivés
en travaillant d'abord un pays puis 2
puis 8 puis 27 un conseil européen deux
nuits sans sommeil des négociations
difficiles mais à la fin on y arrive par
pourquoi parce qu'on sait que c'est un
défi de civilisation qu'on doit
absolument réussir mon rôle aujourd'hui
en france c'est comment ce grand
objectif continental on est le seul
continent au monde qui veut sa
neutralité on arrive à le décliner pour
les 66 millions de français partout là
où ils vivent c'est au fond ben ça va
être paris comme dit le président au
service des territoires que dans chaque
bassin de vie les bornes électriques la
rénovation des bâtiments
l'artificialisation des sols soient des
choses qui soit pas juste des textes
européens sont pas juste des lois
françaises soit des choses que les
français voient se déployer pour que en
2030 soit là on doit être et donc ça
veut dire qu'on doit accélérer très
franchement enfin certains sujets pas
forcément tous aux mêmes et des
territoires qui ont déjà fait beaucoup
qui sur la qualité de l'eau sont très
avancées mais qui doit faire beaucoup
plus sur la rénovation des logements
donc on va faire des contrats au niveau
des bassins de vie on va travailler que
les collectivités ont réglé les élus
entre avec les entreprises les
associations parce qu'aujourd'hui la
transition écologique c'est à la fois
encore des grands règlement européen
pour organiser notre économie à la bonne
échelle mais c'est aussi un travail très
locale très concret et on va très mal et
on va parler si vous savez mon cher mais
juste pour reprendre la question du lien
sur ses voitures électriques la fin des
voitures thermiques en tout cas de la
vente des voitures thermiques pour 2035
vous le disais en france c'était 2040
l'objectif est ce que la france sera
prête pour 2035 et c'est agnès pannier
une ag qui ait la ministre en charge la
transition énergétique qui est en charge
de ce dossier parce que il ya aussi des
contraintes d'électrification il ya
aussi des contraintes industrielles donc
la discussion se poursuit mais c'est pas
trop tôt du coup c'est moi mais il faut
aider aussi les français parce que
évidemment changer de véhicule alors que
le véhicule électrique est 50% plus cher
en général qu'un véhicule thermique
enfin ça se fait pas comme ça c'est bien
pour ça que je vous dis que ce projet
écologique il est pour nous un projet
aussi social qui doit accompagner tous
les français mais comment
aujourd'hui on a une prime de loin dans
les aides à la conversion déjà annoncé
qu on voulait aller plus loin puisqu'on
a annoncé que l'état allait organiser un
système de leasing de location mais ça
c'est pour les familles les plus
modestes
enfin c'est déjà bien ça non mais qui
sont ils ceux qui précise mais il ya des
gens qui sortent des critères sociaux
que vous avez choisi pour le leasing à
moins de 5 à moins de 100 euros
l'objectif et qui pourtant ne peuvent
pas se permettre d'acheter une voiture
électrique savez qu'aujourd'hui dz cela
la voiture électrique c'est 6000 euros
dans de nombreuses situations non
corrélés revenus cd prime à la
conversion qui sont aussi très
importantes c'est aussi l'accompagnement
de la lutte contre la pollution de l'air
dans les agglomérations les fameuses
zones à faibles émissions qui vont nous
obliger et c'est très bien accompagnée
évidemment en particulier en priorité
ceux et celles qui vivent autour de ces
villes où on a un vrai défi de pollution
vers ce que je suis en train de vous
dire c'est qu'on n'a pas aujourd'hui
tous les outils pour y arriver c'est
précisément pour ça qu'on doit continuer
à accélérer renforcer différencier aussi
selon les territoires et moi mon
engagement c'est que la transition
écologique ne se fera que si 66 millions
de français peuvent la faire sont
accompagnés pour la faire que c'est pas
un luxe c'est pas réservé à certains si
ça reste réservé à certains on
n'atteindra pas les objectifs et dont
vous voyez c'est un projet très
différent de celui de jean luc mélenchon
très différents jean luc mélenchon il
dit pas je veux que tous les français
participent ils cherchent des coupables
jean luc mélenchon il fait de la com
c'est finalement presque du greenwashing
écologique il passe son temps à dire
l'écologie ça se résoudraient pas un
claquement de doigts aux quelques jours
c'est des amendements qu'on a vu à
l'assemblée depuis cinq ans j'étais
député j'ai vu les amendements en une
ligne qui si on les voit tu si on les
écoute règle le tout on voit bien tout
ce que toute la discussion qu'on a
depuis maintenant quelques minutes
montrent que faire la transition
écologique c'est pas de fabas comme
c'est pas de faire des incantations sait
pas faire des grands des manchots c'est
le président de la région corse a été
celui qui a repris le terme de
planification écologique qui avait été
lancée par jean luc mélenchon c'est dire
que finalement tout n'est pas à jeter
dans le programme mais ça veut pas dire
12e choix de votre bouche la
planification telle qu'on la conçoit
sait comment réconcilier les français
qui veulent qu'on aille plus vite on
leur donnera confiance sur les jalons et
qui puisse regarder sur les attend et
qu'on puisse donner confiance à ceux qui
pensent que ça va trop vite ou qui sont
passées accompagnés pour la montrer que
c'est réaliste c'est pas de la
planification pour interdire ce n'est
pas branché j'avais coupable c'est pas
pour bloquer au fond le pays de manière
autoritaire c'est pour dire on peut y
arriver on sait où on va on va
l'organiser et on va l'organiser et
jeudi cette dimension buisson et
colonisant mélange assez réaliste c'est
dangereux c'est aventureuse c'est
totalement mensonger c'est totalement
attentatoire c'est au fond d'écologie
magique oui si on considère que l'on
peut il a fait des amendements comme ça
un amendement pour rénover les passoires
thermiques une ligne
j'adorerais que ce soit possible en une
ligne alors si quelqu'un avait trouvé la
baguette magique pour le faire on
l'aurait déjà fait les français seraient
d'ailleurs très heureux d'avoir déjà des
factures de chauffage qui en une ligne
puisse être baissés la rénovation des
bâtiments vous savez depuis jean louis
borloo c'est un objectif majeur on a
enfin en 2020 réussi à rénover 700 mille
logements dans l'année et on est en
train de le refaire en 2021 et il faut
qu'on leur fasse chaque année mais
rénové 700 mille logements c'est pas une
ligne c'est un travail avec des acteurs
économiques industrielles avec les
français eux mêmes avec ma prime reynard
avec des aides financières avec du
travail maison par maison et donc vous
pouvez d'un côté dit c'est quand même
terrible qui reste des passoires
thermiques en france vous pouvez vous
dire comment on a un plan aujourd'hui on
a les moyens on a les alliés pour que en
2027 on est éradiqué le rassure
thermique
est important vous parliez de plan b si
on veut comprendre la méthode ce que
vous êtes nouvelle ministre ambitions
écologiques cohésion des territoires
donc a priori on est parti pour un
dialogue hyper local sur la transition
écologique vous avez vous-même annoncé
que vous alliez faire un grand tour de
france des communes mais on a du mal à
saisir en fait quelle va être la vôtre
méthode pour rallier tout le monde est
ce que c'est la fin de l'état grand
ordonnateur et que finalement ça va être
la parole à chacune des collectivités
alors c'est effectivement à l'échelle
des bassins de vie qu'on peut organiser
comment on pense le développement
économique les logements le transport
l'occupation des sols c'est aujourd'hui
si
un bassin de vie en général ça veut dire
un groupement de communes qui ressemble
à une intercommunalité parfois c'est une
communauté communes parfois si
l'agglomération j'ai discuté avec tout
le monde vous allez au tour de france
d'aller voir les régions vous allez voir
les départements vous allez voir que les
communes mais je vais pas voir les
institutions je vais voir un territoire
et on fait venir tout le monde pour
savoir dans ce territoire qui sont les
acteurs pertinents qui fait quoi comment
s'organise et comment on contractualise
comment fait au fond que chacun prenne
ses responsabilités vous allez passer
des contrats avec chaque bassin de vie
sur les questions tournaient donc si
vous avez demandé la relance on a fait
un contrat de relancer transition
écologique c'était une première démarche
ou dans 850 bassin de vie on a défini ce
que la relance devaient financer et
comment on commençait sur des projets de
transition écologique qui était
d'intérêt et voyez collectif a accéléré
c'est la base mais cette base là il faut
maintenant qu'on l'a travail qu on la
renforce et qu on signe des contrats
pourquoi pas qu'on responsabilise les
uns les autres après dans chaque bassin
de vie parfois ce sera les communes qui
se mettront en avant par ce seront les
départements est ce que les est-ce que
les contrats sont les mêmes pour les
objectifs sont les mêmes pour tout le
monde je prends un exemple simple là
imaginons que certains territoires
veuille l'interdiction de la chasse le
week-end pour des questions d écologique
est ce qu'on peut imaginer qu'il y ait
plusieurs gars à plusieurs endroits des
choses différentes là on mélange le
sujet je vous donne un exemple
la chasse pour moi je vous le dis très
franchement les règles sont nationales
la mise en oeuvre des horaires des lieux
etc c'est des mères on va pas le faire
oui on parlera pas fin des contrats sur
les horaires de chasse ça c'est pas ça
le sujet non mais le week-end par
exemple mais c'est pas c'est pas on
l'avait cité vous même dans une radio
figaro comme un des exemples de
différenciation ou deux en tout cas de
de dialogue mais super locale je vais
pas moi faire le tour des contrats des
horaires de chasse je vous donne un
exemple très concret l'artificialisation
des sols nous avons un objectif c'est
que dans les dix prochaines années nous
division par deux notre rythme
d'artificialisation pour laisser des
sols vivants qui notamment nous aide
beaucoup à gérer des innovations parce
que si tous les sols sont bétonnées il
ya des grosses innovations le sujet de
l'artificialisation des sols il ne
s'oppose pas du tout pareil quand vous
êtes je pense par exemple le bassin
minier vous avez d immense friche
industrielle et que dans ces territoires
là l'enjeu c'est plutôt de les dépolluer
de les réutiliser potentiellement d'y
installer des logements voire de les re
nature et c'est pas du tout même débat
je pense à des régions plus dans l'ouest
de la france où le sujet là c'est que le
logement a pris beaucoup de place et où
il faut maintenant se demander comment
on développe des emplois à côté ces
logements ça n'aurait aucun sens que je
donne des objectifs homogène d'artifice
et son essor dans la mise en oeuvre dans
le bassin minier où dans le morbihan ça
n'aurait aucun sens c'est d'ailleurs les
élus légitimes en on dirait ça n'a pas
de sens on a un objectif national
comment ensuite on l'appli comment le
différencie on a même chose sur la
rénovation des bâtiments rénovés 700 mm
logement
c'est évidemment lié à quand est ce que
vraiment été construit avec quelles
méthodes
est ce qu'ils sont on n'a pas la même
logique de la rénovation quand vous êtes
dans une banlieue vous avez beaucoup de
tours de logements sociaux ou quand vous
avez un territoire rural avec des
maisons
s'accompagner d'une remise à plat aussi
des compétences des collectivités quand
on vous entend en effet ça peut amener
aussi une réflexion là dessus ma logique
c'est pas de faire des grands plans des
grandes circulaire des grands règlement
puis mon bureau c'est que si dans un
territoire donné et un acteur qui dit
moi je veux responsable de ça je veux
signer le contrat avec vous parce que
c'est ma collectivité mois département
ou à l'intercommunalité mois la commune
qui va faire si c'est cohérent et qu'on
a des résultats et qu'on s'organise bien
moi je vais pas être la ministre qui va
empêcher de faire donc c'est plus de
décentralisation sans nouvel endroit sur
la décentralisation du sein de résultats
si on doit pour avoir des résultats se
donner des marges de manoeuvre je ne
vais pas être la ministre qui va
empêcher de faire je vais au contraire
est un ministre qui va créer les
conditions que dans chaque territoire et
si les collectivités ne souhaite pas si
par exemple la région hôte france pour
ne citer qu'elles refusent d
implantation d'éoliennes voulait squeezé
vous faites quoi on vient d'ailleurs de
la planification du dialogue local les
régions sont pas responsables de la
politique énergétique de leur territoire
et pourtant elles investissent
subventionne des associations
comme on dit la vérité sur les prix les
français veulent et ils ont raison je
veux aussi évidemment le président le
veut la première ministre veut c'est
d'ailleurs sa responsabilité de premier
ministre c'est unique au monde de faire
cette cohérence planification s'il ya
des endroits où quand on fait le tour
des bassins de vie qu'en dit voilà on va
aller je passe dans le douaisis a lens
on a une difficulté parce que tel ou tel
acteur ont dit qu'ils veulent pas faire
on va le dire aux français on va rendre
tout ça transparent c'est le conseil
national a refondé qu on arrosera
m'excuser mais on a vu où il fallait
falloir imposer l'iata
c'est une question à condition là si
aujourd'hui il n'ya pas d'élus qui
foncièrement ne veulent pas faire la
transition souvent ils manquent d'outils
il manque de moyens il manque
d'organisation pour y arriver ensuite si
les gens qui s'opposent à la neutralité
carbone qui s'opposent à la restauration
de la biodiversité qui s'oppose à ce que
notre ère soit plus au nord d où va
responsabiliser chacun à vider par le
contrat les objectifs qu ici et par le
suivi aussi la mise en oeuvre un mot sur
le conseil national de la fondation
julien puisque vous en parlez oui parce
que la neutralité carbone a été cité en
parmi les sujets qui seront discutés au
sein de ce conseil national de l'offre
refondation annoncée par le président de
la république est ce qu'on va on va
assister finalement à une nouvelle
convention citoyenne pour le climat
aujourd'hui on voit qu'on a un pays qui
est très fatigué on voit qu'on a des
crises dont on sort des choses qu'on a
traversées qui sont durs on a des très
grands défis devant nous défi climatique
on va parler le défi sécurité
internationale la guerre en ukraine on a
aussi un défi économique on a toujours
un défi de santé sanitaire aujourd'hui
beaucoup de français ne comprennent plus
les tenants et les aboutissants la
décision publique j'ai l'impression tout
au moins comme ça sans comprendre au
fond pourquoi on prend ses décisions
comment on les prend et donc les
français je crois sont en demande de
transparence ce qu'on va faire et que
nous soyons conseil c'est qu'on va
ouvrir le capot de décision publique on
va associer toutes les forces vives et
on va faire aussi que chacun puisse
partager à la fois ses contraintes sa
vision est que au fond on recrée du
consensus sur le diagnostic n'a
apparemment
il ya un parlement transparent avec des
séances publiques évidemment mais c'est
une étape qui est avant qu'on vote la
loi partager le constat quel est l'état
du pays quelles sont les contraintes qui
se posent à nous ouvrir le capot cette
décision de l'exécutif c'est bien en
amour dessus ensuite évidemment le
travail du parlement le parlement suite
il évalue y contrôler les parlementaires
vont évidemment être associés mais on a
besoin dans d'autres pays aussi pour
recréer la confiance démocratique que
nous en fassions toute la transparence
sur les tenants et les aboutissants
séquelles cet outil est qu'il n'existe
pas déjà avec le conseil économique
social et environnemental
c'est exactement la mission du saison
mais sauf qu'au conseil économique
social et environnemental vous n'avez
pas les parlementaires vous n'avez pas
les forces mais ils peuvent tout à fait
les associés ne s'est pas hors jeu je
vous rassure le conseil économique
social et l'otan sera largement associé
à ce travail mais ce que veut faire le
président et je crois que c'est
absolument nécessaire c'est que nous
ayons une méthode qui nous permettent de
présenter aux français et de partager le
diagnostic les contraintes les objectifs
et que les français les plus
l'impression que les décisions publiques
ton duo comme si c'était une chose
auquel il n'est pas faux compris la
fabrique quelques questions à la mise de
la cohésion des territoires avant de
parler des législatives
est-ce que des économies seront demandés
aux collectivités durant son quinquennat
on parle d'un chiffre de 10 milliards là
là aussi je vais pas vous répondre c'est
pas pour ou contre on est dans un pays
où on a un enjeu de finances publiques
on a aussi un enjeu vraiment parler
d'investissements la transition
écologique sont des investissements et
donc dans la planification qu'on cherche
on va travailler avec des collectivités
sur la manière dont on rend les choses
possibles mais dont on est aussi
respectueux l'argent public c'est un
grand défi pour l'état mais on va pas
faire l'état compte des collectivités il
n'y a pas d'un côté un état qui a fait
des efforts des collectivités qui
n'offrait aucune d'ailleurs je pense
qu'elle ne vois pas les choses comme ça
donc ça vanne en rien ils disent
qu'elles en font qu'elles rendent des
budgets du livre mais l'état fait aussi
des efforts dans de nombreux domaines
aujourd'hui rue vous allez demander de
les efforts supplémentaires tous les
français font des efforts on fait tout
le monde fait des efforts aujourd'hui le
bouclier tarifaire c'est un effort de
l'état c'est aussi un effort des
français parce qu'ils payent aussi
aujourd'hui plus cher l'essence à la
pompe donc on est dans une situation
économique internationale collective qui
est ce chiffre de 10 milliards c'est le
bon ça sera dans cette fourchette les
sadiques c'est 10 milliards 2027 c'est
pas 10 milliards aujourd'hui on n'est
pas en train de dire qu'on va baisser
les dotations donc c'est des choses qui
sont assez complexe à organiser mais
nommant noble et elle est limitée leur
nez la hausse de leurs dépenses non ce
qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va planifier
on va donner de la prévisibilité on va
donner de la visibilité c'est une très
grande demande des élus c'est de savoir
non pas chaque année ce qu'ils ont envie
de faire un enfant prochain je pensais
pas une bonne relation c'est de créer un
chemin où chacun sait ce qu'il a à faire
les moyens qu'il a pour le faire et que
les choses soient partagées des aides
que l'état les aide à l'état aide les
français à faire face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie les besoins les
collectivités est ce qui aura des aides
pour les collectivités pour les aider
elle aussi à faire face à la hausse des
prix de l'énergie s'est totalement lié à
ce que je viens de vous dire c'est que
il faut qu'on fasse allah aussi la
transparence où on en est et ce que les
collectivités en difficulté ou est ce qu
est ce qu on peut potentiellement se
dire bah tiens on va vous aider à
investir pour peut-être justement
rénover des bâtiments publics justement
on arrive à et dans l'immédiat il ya des
collectivités en difficulté vous savez
très bien ça bien sûr mais à celle des
écrits l'énergie est ce que dans
l'immédiat elles vont avoir des êtres sa
collectivité je vais pas ici vous fais
ma liste mais vous savez qu'on en était
responsable et que dans notre pays on
est des gens qui regardent les problèmes
trop nos solutions et on va les trouver
ensemble mais je vais pas vous annoncer
la ce soir ou ce matin un grand plan de
6 milliards pour payer les factures des
collectivités ça n'aurait aucun sens
c'est pas comme ça que l'état fonctionne
si vous réfléchissez adn mais on
réfléchit évidemment à ce que les
collectivités puissent continuer à
investir c'est ça notre objectif pas
transition écologique l'accompagnement
des français les enjeux même on a parlé
d'éducation et de santé que le président
veut remettre au coeur des territoires
il est aujourd'hui à gaillac dans le
tarn il parle sécurité évidemment il
aura autour de lui des élus locaux donc
on veut donner à chacun des moyens
d'agir mais de faire aux responsabilités
de manière transparente
ah oui avec des projections des
instituts de sondage qui sont pas
forcément follement enthousiaste pour
pouvoir la majorité présidentielle le
dernier par exemple boutonne contre 275
et 315 des députés est ce que vous ne
craignez pas un accident électoral pour
reprendre l'expression du patron du
groupe modem patrick mignola nous ont
fait campagne ça et moi je fais campagne
je suis le candidat toi même la première
ministre fait campagne tous les
ministres feront campagne vous ont fait
aussi campagne parce que la légitimité
notre action tout cas priez pour moi je
suis devant vous parce que j'ai été élu
député en 2017 c'est essentiel d'avoir
cette fidélité un territoire et de
continuer aussi à se présenter devant
les français mais ce continent excusez
moi mais dimanche à la messe que est ce
que quand même face à toutes ces
instituts de sondage qui quand même
laissé
ouverte la possibilité que vous n'ayez
pas la majorité absolue il n'ya pas
quand même une forme de motivation de se
dire voilà finalement là on est on est
vraiment au pied du mur ont fait
campagne deux ont présenté le projet
d'avoir de la stabilité de l'ambition
pour un pays un moment justement l'un
des grands défis et puis on a aussi la
clarté sur nos valeurs quand je vois et
le conseil d'état fait quelque chose
d'intéressant ces jours ci c'est qu'il a
rayé d'un trait de plume l'existence du
parti socialiste et d'europe écologie
les verts maintenant dimanche alors
c'est tout est candidat l'étiquette
youtube donc ils sont tous
mélenchonistes tous ceux qui vous disent
au fond que il y aurait une coalition de
gens très différents qui ont des idées
différentes pour traversant c'est pas ça
du tout qui s'est passé le conseil
d'état a mis très bien nous on n'a pas
bradé ou un nouvel appel tous ensemble
ça va avancer
mais on n'a pas bradé nos valeurs dans
quelques circonscriptions on n'est pas
en train de faire une alliance contre
nature de gens qui pensent le contraire
pour ce faire et dire nous on n'est pas
ambigu sur la russie on n'est pas ambigu
sur l'europe on n'est pas ambigu sur la
stratégie énergétique
on n'est pas ambigu sur la manière dont
on veut faire vivre nos institutions et
donc on fait campagne est en outre en
français le choix qu'ils ont à faire
qu'un choix décisif est-ce qu'on n'a un
projet stable ambitieux qui permet
justement de réunir les français
d'avancé face à ces grands défis avec
une méthode qu'on a présenté beaucoup de
transparence relations publiques le
conseil national l'heure et fondations
de la planification pour que chacun voit
où va la transition écologique au coeur
c'est la mission la première ministre ou
alors on en fasse un projet est un
projet qui a énormément d'ambiguïté et
qui a un objectif l'affaiblissement de
la france à ce titre le programme de
jean luc mélenchon il est tout à fait
jumeaux celui de marine le pen oui vous
avez vous avez parlé de jumeaux de la
peur est-ce que c'est pas un peu le
chiffon rouge je veux que vous agirez
j'assume totalement mes propos j'imagine
puisque ce sont les programmes jumeaux
ils cherchent l'affaiblissement ils se
font la courte échelle entre eux ils
sont en fait dans la même approche de la
politique qui serait vont une affaire de
déclaration et ils jouent effectivement
des peurs non pas pour proposer des
solutions non pas pour réunir les
français et pour les diviser pour les
scinder pour au fond toujours chercher
des coupables notre vision de la
politique c'est qu'aujourd'hui si on ne
fait pas l'unité du pays 6 n'importe pas
de la stabilité si on se donne pas les
moyens d'agir concrètement on vient d'en
parler dans chaque territoire pour
chaque français que cette transition est
soit à la fois sociales que ce soit du
mieux vivre partout qu'au fond on
appelle aussi notre pays eh bien on a
devant nous un agenda qui n'est pas le
nôtre et qu'on combat et ont fait
campagne et on verra ensuite évidemment
comment les français voteront mais moi
j'ai un message pour les français et ce
sera le dernier projet qu'ils aillent
voter qu'ils expriment leur voix parce
que la première chose d'une élection
c'est faux qui la participation est donc
dans ce premier rappel c'est qu'ils
votent et qu'ensuite ils votent pour un
projet de stabilité d'unités d'ambition
de clarté et qui n'a pas bradé ses
valeurs pour quelques circonscriptions
merci à mes démons chalain merci
beaucoup d'avoir été notre invité au
regard de la voix du nord julien des
crimes non élucidés au coeur du pôle
d'éco kaiser qui fait la une de votre
journal merci j'ai une âme à ce niveau
ça non
[Musique]